Air is a remarkable substance.
Not only does it
allow us to breathe,
which I think we can all
agree is a good thing,
but if you compress
it and contain it,
you can have loads of fun.
Like defying the
laws of physics.
Or for wacky furniture.
Whack!
See?
The secret to understanding
and using compressed
air is to realize that
all it wants to do
is stop being compressed air.
It wants to escape
and in so doing air
teaches us valuable science
on pressure differentials
and conservation of energy.
If air in one part of a
container is compressed,
it will apply pressure
to all other parts
until all areas are
the same pressure.
This is due to
conservation of energy.
When a container of compressed
air is open to the atmosphere,
the high pressure
inside equalizes
with a lower pressure
outside, producing
a force as the air escapes.
And whatever is containing the
compressed air needs to have
the material
strength to withstand
the pressure differential,
otherwise, it will fail.
To sum up, pressure
changes will be transferred
to all parts of the container.
Give something at high
pressure an opening,
and it will take it
and escape with force.
And finally, whatever you
do, make sure the container
you're using is strong enough.
So now you know.
But do our researchers know?
Yes, they do.
The jumper has
cleverly demonstrated
a basic pneumatic system.
He adds kinetic energy,
with his jump, which causes
a pressure change in the bag.
And due to
conservation of energy,
the kinetic energy is
transferred to her,
and she then transfers that
same energy to the bedside table
via her head.
How about something a
little more high tech?
Surely these amateur
rocket engineers
understand pneumatics.
Turns out, they don't.
The young researcher
was trying to compress
air by jumping on the pump.
Unfortunately, he misses.
But Oliver does it.
When the pump is pressed, the
pressure differential created
applies a force that
launches the rocket.
Good to get a closer
look at the physics.
Understanding the science
allows you to take
advantage of the science.
Like building a
beach trampoline.
Fun times.
Yeah, less fun times.
The membrane of the beach
ball didn't have the material
strength to contain the higher
pressure produced by our more
sure footed researcher.